what am i doing i'm a 30 year old grown
ass man
getting in a fight in beverly hills on a
pickup basketball game this is supposed
to be fun
and i'm getting triggered and reactive
to the fact where i get in a physical
fist fight
that was a wake-up call for me my
emotions are in control of me
i'm not in control of my emotions where
i was like i need some support i need
some coaching some therapy some
workshops some freaking
whatever i'll try whatever that was
really part of the process of me
learning about vulnerability i wasn't a
vulnerable human being before
30. i wasn't willing to let people see
who i was
my pain what i'd been through because
i'd been conditioned as a man
growing up that you don't feel pain you
don't show emotion anger is okay but you
can't be vulnerable you can't cry
when i started to go through some of
these workshops and therapies and
coaches and it's extremely uncomfortable
but i also found out this
is probably the greatest superpower in
the world revealing who you are to
someone in a vulnerable way
makes you powerful